hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to please don't touch
anything hey man I mean I already said
hi but I'm talking about this story in
the game here man I need to take a
bathroom break stay here for a moment
wait what is this panel for and why is
there a big red button in the middle of
it and why do I have such an urge to
press it just stay here I'll be right
back and don't touch anything you know I
always love it when people say the name
of the game in the dialogue that they're
talking ha boink
oh damn it I missed the button what is
that hello-o it only goes on a boink oh
I love a countdown that's always a good
thing
already blew up the world yeah or I grew
a mushroom apparently I heart mushrooms
I do indeed
okay so I did a thing great I wonder
what would happen if I actually waited
for the guy to come back it'd probably
like farc far cry 4 was that the game in
Far Cry 4 in the beginning of the game
the guy I've never played it myself but
if the guy tells you that he's gonna
come right back I wonder if you wait
here long enough if he's gonna come back
I have no idea
probably why I say the number 6 6 6 on
that desk
also I need me oh god they're
instructions hang on one grab your
screwdriver two gree your hammer for
work for three oh god I don't know what
that is why is there an equation on
there I don't know what that means
was that say correct correct
oh is it upside down these are clues
obviously four things that I need to do
in the game I think why is there a
pentagram on there how long has it been
I have no idea what's the wait around
for this I don't know how long I'm gonna
be waiting for it oh great thanks man
you've really helped me what took you so
long
something can happen really like what
the apocalypse you've got to have an
education to run this machine let's go
are you calling me stupid I'll blow off
the damn city god damn it
you have to restart dammit alright
huh boink
all right this has gotta be ah I know
I'm doing what happens if I press it a
whole bunch yeah oh hey oh cool
Oh perfect ooh know what that is oh oh
hang on okay so a combination of four
there's only so many possibilities I
could probably brute force my way
through that I don't know how to do that
and what is this okay one two three two
one two okay so on line three
technically line four of the
instructions there's numbers so there's
one one one two one button
no okay one one one one two two one
no I did it go away 3 1 2 2 1 1 damn it
okay maybe uh okay
so if I'm looking at the correct thing
upside down then they'd be pointing it
bottom right bottom left bottom left
bottom right damn it
okay Wow I'm not doing good I'm trying
guys I'm trying what happens if I press
the button some more something gonna
happen oh yes yeah Oh what is that hello
hi
Oh what the hell whoa wait don't do that
what oh god damn it
okay so running yeah it's still running
okay we're good all right we're back in
the game god damn it is really lucky I
just changed my recording setup for this
video and I can handle it crashing now
okay that's good okay we're fine all
right so I need to press this whole
bunch what happens if I keep pressing Oh
what did I get what is that what is that
does this a dunce no that says dumb dumb
that says dummy
god dammit I'm not a dummy oh man okay
hang on okay grab your screwdriver grab
your hammer work and then whatever the
hell that says okay so there's something
to this color panel there's something on
that obviously the clues are on that
sheet do I can I hammer that hi what the
hell is that I don't know what do I do
B D 1 D 7 and 4 and it looks like this
is something missing there I think
there's like a slot or something what is
that is it a clock I think it's a clock
wait is it wait a minute hang on yeah
yeah it's a clock can a hammer it that
break it no
ah come on that was in the middle of the
thing it's still ticking away I'm not
stupid
I'm the smarty I'm not a dummy get me
something else
[Music]
the [ __ ] that Oh what the [ __ ] is that
okay I get it okay Oh God
hit the baby with a hammer Oh God oh
jeez oh it's got a shield okay that
makes sense okay hang on wait oh god why
does it as bro why does it have Plus
bubbling tumors all over the place oh my
god oh [ __ ] oh it's dripping blood
towards the reset button oh I know what
you doing oh [ __ ]
don't do it don't do it man don't do it
man oh whoa that's an upset baby oh I
don't know what that is
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god I got some weird heart artery
combination art on the wall there great
I'm collecting posters I just beat a
blood baby to death with a hammer I
can't believe I said those words
[Music]
awaiting input
what do you mean awaiting input button
Oh button button button play the buttons
why there's so many buttons I didn't do
anything I didn't unlock a secret oh god
damn it
okay trying to remember where the
buttons were oh jesus oh god I think oh
god my brain is warped okay thank you
for cooperating you got the job
it's - my name is Stanley
I think judging by this over on the
right side yeah I know my name now I
think okay God is there anything else I
can hammer okay so there's got to be
something here with this this color like
this color is the next puzzle that I
need to do so it's got to be like I
tried hammering this red can i hammer
any of the paintings no oh man this is
much more intriguing than I thought it'd
be I had no idea would have so many
different options to it but okay now I'm
touching everything I'm still wondering
why there's a pentagram right there oh
[Music]
that's Roman numerals oh then that would
be one three two two three one okay one
three it's not the colors but it's
something yes I would I wish I knew okay
so there's arrangement of four buttons
what if I do the thing it was bottom
right left left right
okay oh my god I was right okay I was
right so what does this mean d4 I don't
know a d4 means oh my god are you
kidding me I gotta get up to two 47
Jesus
okay closing in on it 276 wait a minute
wait what wait why did it
[Music]
No
oh there we go yes okay I got it yeah
yeah what's green okay I'm still causing
an apocalypse but I caused something new
to happen yeah I did a thing okay good
for me man good for me okay but I think
I think there's a there's a 666 here I
think if you click that thing 666 times
something else happens but I don't have
the patience for that okay so let me go
back to the 1 3 2 2 3 1 okay so is that
a switch yeah oh hello numbers ok
numbers 1 1 1 2 1
Oh only four numbers Jesus um those
numbers in the equation 8 3 6 7 yes ok
got it all right
ok this is good oh jeez okay so this is
next to the 666 does that mean another 6
6 6 is the other thing
[Music]
there's little dots there's little dots
by work which is line four which is line
three so dodge dot dot dot dot okay so
it's line four so the fourth row down do
this no fourth row across no dammit
okay I thought I had something there all
right but it's 1 1 2 4 3 and there's 1 2
3 so 1 2 4 3 yes all right count it up
whoa oh so we had some sort of
singularity happen there and it sucked
it all into another dimension right I'm
so sorry whoever lives in that city
I am wrecking shop here but I'm doing
good I'm doing good ok all right let me
try the other way there we go okay ah
what is that whoa whoa oh whoa I don't
look good
someone had a bit of a accident on that
button over there all right oh wow what
the hell kaboom kaboom oh man
Oh God zap Pluto Pluto's not a planet
anymore so say oh my god
Oh how am I gonna remember these numbers
oh god I can't remember that how am I
gonna be able to oh oh jeez oh jeez
was that a person oh jeez Scoob
aw jeez oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
all someone died here oh wow okay all
pac-man okay
oh cool geez nothing up there
no secrets secrets whoo hello dot do T
whoa
Morse oh wait
ah okay Morse dot oh stop
bender was that on the sides of it okay
this means something here this means
something okay so if it wants me to do
Morse code don't do it dot I can
translate zero on one to Morse code oh
man it's been so long since I learned
Morse code um D is - dot dot o is o is
triple - and T is just - I believe so if
zero is dot one is - it'd be - o dot dot
that seems like the appropriate - - - -
oh my god
holy crap I haven't thought about Morse
code in years oh my god oh my god I'm
just amazed at myself there everyone
give me a moment a high-five myself a
million times I'm gonna leave that
totally uncut so you guys know that I
didn't look it up pretty [ __ ] like
that yeah
Oh Pat me a million times on the back
how that hurt okay and I kind of flooded
everybody I guess but that's cool oh man
oh I got that or maybe I just got lucky
with something else but I got that holy
[ __ ] look at me oh look at me okay
enough enough self-congratulations
enough masturbatory session here okay so
okay whoo all right which way did I go
before that way okay so I think I got
everything there is there anything up
here I'm out of breath now it's too much
okay so what if these these dots here
are also Morse code and it's like zero
zero one zero zero zero zero one ah oh
my god hello buddy all right sorry about
that everybody else that robot needed a
place to live I think he's starting to
lay eggs so you better tuck in for a
while he's gonna be stampeding oh this
is cool it's cool I get to use my brain
Oh better kill all humans that's nice
okay so poof all right anyway three two
two three one okay which way I go on the
other time
it's a numpad so I did I still haven't
figured out the colors or have I know I
haven't figured out the colors the
colors was like a basic one that was one
of the earlier ones there's got to be
something simple to that gree your
hammer grier hammer green why is it
green hammer does that mean something
could it be is it green that's clearly
not an A something there it could be
[Music]
green all green no oh oh I just noticed
on the bottom on it it's eight squared
plus three squared that could be eight -
eight - hang on eight - eight - damn it
man maybe I already know okay so like I
would think that the dot pattern would
be this because it's the exact same
number but I can't seem to get it unless
I was doing it wrong like the reverse
and let me let me restart I'm gonna try
the UH the number pattern thing damn it
god damn it
[ __ ] that okay hang on no no don't know
what I'm doing there whoa what the [ __ ]
is that what oh my god are you serious
but when did they decide to put a
minigame in and within a game oh god
it's game ception
yeah why am I doing this why am i
blowing up the town said a horrible
thing to do I'm about to hit the ground
one block left one block and you came
over me you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you man [ __ ] you
alright fine I'll get ya I'll get you
next time
I wasn't ready for you this time okay so
left alright it's only try eight - three
- yes okay Wow
[Music]
is there a date around here
why oh oh I went into the future the
moon is all exploded
oh so if I oh I thought I had to enter
some what is well I hang on I saw
something in the bottom right [ __ ] me
god damn it or it'll pop up again maybe
damn it god damn it up to the right [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
ah there see hello hi oh it's papers
please all of a sudden how about a big
no to you [ __ ] off oh jeez what's this
made by the same people all I didn't
know that Oh Horace don't sky got all
got all grave there okay sorry I'm sorry
Han let me do that again
oh man I did not know that this was made
by the same people I should have known
by the by the styling of it what I got a
badge oh I got an hour stops cut edge
thank you
I know a lot of people have wanted me to
play that um and the odd thing was I was
gonna do a let's play a bit like three
years ago when it first came out but
then for some reason I got distracted or
something or I didn't know if it would
do well or something like that or I
don't know I got I got I got sidetracked
okay let's go back in time wow that is
farther than I wanted to go ah yes
okay cool
all right I got it I don't know how many
of these I'm gonna be able to get I can
only assume it's got the number six six
six by it and I notice now that kind of
looks like a star and there's a red
pentagram up top so if I draw that it
gives me five right [ __ ] I guess I could
wider yes Oh God
what the [ __ ] are you oh hi
can I blow you up please or I can't even
press the button anymore you're leaking
blood everywhere I'm sorry for summoning
you demon could you please go away now
oh boy
I think I remember those symbols around
the Illuminati triangle thing but okay
bye now
I'm gonna go away have fun oh jeez okay
alright so alright I gotta figure out
the color thing
this one's staring at me in the face I
know it I don't want to look up the
answers yet I don't I've been doing so
good [ __ ] I Chi Chi I know I've been
doing real good it's fine
maybe maybe since the other one was
upside down on the arrows maybe this one
is top left right right left damn it
[Music]
what if it's not green what if it's gr
BB and that could mean green red blue
blue yes okay oh we're counting up again
whoa everything went up is it why does
that do that I mean it's cool this poor
town why is this console so powerful oh
man but I got it I got it okay all right
okay what else even is there there's a
lot of unlit lights here I'm not a
hundred percent sure what else I could
possibly do okay so I did I did the
thing for the color panel what if I do
this up right right there oh that's one
oh that's one two oh sorry oh geez oh
well I'm sorry about that
I think I got everything on the right
side whoo I got everything on the right
side okay
I'm doing great how many are left one
two three four five six seven eight and
nine
ooh nine left that's a lot I don't know
if I can do that
wow that is a lot of man where else do I
go from here
Oh what else is there god damn it okay
don't miss don't miss Oh miss boink yeah
I did it I just needed to clear the city
you drop all the bomb yeah press restart
to continue
I got it did I get him oh I got a
sticker down at the bottom thank you
very much okay I got to figure out how
to get back to that thing though I don't
remember what I did is the bra oh did I
do that I did the button combination
okay so bottom right left left right all
right this was the thing
so I'm pretty sure if I click this 666
times something's gonna happen
BAM okay so now either I press this
button or yeah I press the ribbond huh
boink whoa what is that why is one
broken I do not know what do I do with
that I am not sure what do I do
what is this what is this oh okay so I
got it wait I know this there were the
symbols the symbols when the thing was
on the screen the symbols when the
Illuminati was up it was the two waves
it was Oh what was it I was the the
waiting sign ah [ __ ] the moon no the key
the key was definitely part of it and
now it's just one of the other ones so I
gotta figure it out wow the demon symbol
turned weird but the Illuminati one had
different symbols ah okay the Luna and
the aluminum a t1 had different symbols
but I don't know if I have the patience
to click 666 times again to get back to
that but but that's a possibility okay
so that's another one though that's
another one okay so I'm down to seven
left I'm gonna try to get one more on my
own and then I'm a consulting IDE
alright I I'm officially stumped I'm
gonna go consult a guide I'll be right
back I'm sorry to do this I I was really
trying but I was struggling I I know
there's some other stuff that I'm
missing here but man I don't know all
right I'll be right back though whoa
okay I would not have been able to get
this one so this one is relation to the
line the third line with those numbers
in it
with a 1 1 1 to 1 1 1 1 2 2 1 & 3 1 2 2
1 1 how and XIV [ __ ] ok 1 2 1 1 okay
ah 1 2 1 1 why was that 1 2 1 1
ah that's what it was talking about oh
the music you need to reproduce the
music that's genius I never would have
gotten that holy [ __ ] right right middle
left left left middle right okay I got
it hanging let me clear this out right
right middle left left left middle right
oh my god that is amazing and holy [ __ ]
I destroyed everything again but wow wow
it he wowed he wow I never would have
gotten that in a million million years
alright next one next one next one we're
supposedly supposed to tap this oh I
thought that Oh pizanno Leonardo who the
hell of pizanno Leonardo is that on my
screen or is that ballast on my screen
it was something dirty on my screen
don't ask about it don't worry about
it's not a problem
okay so pizanno Leonardo who in the hell
is pizanno Leonardo oh this pizanno
Leonardo is also known as Fibonacci to
solve this riddle enter the first 9
digits of the Fibonacci in the number
keypad ok the Fibonacci sequence is he
ever increasing you know the fibonacci
spiral it's but it's ever increasing in
a certain ratio so it's like 0 1 and
then you combine the previous two
numbers so 0 n + 1 it would still be 1
and then the previous 2 would be 1 + 1
so 2 the next sequence and then 2 + 1
would be 3 3 + 2 5 5 3 8 8 + 5
13 something like that so I need to be
able to put that in but where do I put
that in Oh
Tate oh ah we need the screwdriver
that's what was doing it so the
screwdriver oh okay
[Music]
now how do I get how do I do that ah 1 1
2 3 5 8 1 3 I wouldn't never whoa hi
welcome to the party Cthulhu didn't know
that you would be joining us what a
wonderful time to have you thank you for
being here
alright why I never would have gotten
that holy [ __ ] yeah I'm glad I consulted
it or I'd be banging my head up against
the glass forever okay
oh I couldn't do that can I do that I
may be able to do that it wants me to
change my time on my computer so I get
it I gotta adjust my time in 30 seconds
okay okay ah look at that look at that
the clocks are dangling now all the
clocks are dangling okay so it's gonna
it's gonna be midnight and when it hits
midnight supposedly that's when the
thing happens yeah it's still gonna I
thought it froze for a second there okay
and then something happens and then yeah
what happened that is it's cool thank
you
so I need I think I need to go through
here again Oh what do I do how do I do
that
oh it's the number of dots the number of
dots is what you put in so the first
ones 1 3 2 3 1 1 there we go okay yeah
wow they are gone they are just gone
okay but there was another way to
interpret that if I go went off of the
gray ones instead I went off of the dark
colored ones but I
if I go off the gray ones is that gonna
do something else 3 1 3 3 3 which is
nothing because the last one is four
okay so you can't do it anyway so
restarting okay all right just want to
be sure I'm not smart this ending
consists of connections with other
ending will blow you away to start
reveal the screwdriver open up the panel
okay okay
turn the left side a numeric keypad so
eight three six seven oh okay ah so
these are coordinates on the board these
are coordinates for this so be scratched
off there that's why there was another
button over here those that said d4 so
I'm assuming that that's the D and then
there's probably just another number
that goes around but apparently it's B 4
D 1 D for D 7 and F 4 is the last one
and I don't know where F 4 came from so
but first B 4 which is B is the top four
is the numbers down right is that it
let's try that okay B 4 D 1 D 1 4 and 7
and then F 4 no ok the other way then
so B 4 d 1 4 and 7 and F
know what but that was it wasn't it I'm
gonna do that one later cuz not a
hundred percent sure what I'm doing okay
so okay press the red button ah okay Oh
interesting okay aha oh okay somewhere
over there we go down or across oh there
is whoa yeah I don't know how to do that
I don't know what that is every time you
turn the light the lights around oh I
know this one it's one of these puzzles
okay these are these are really easy I
say as I promptly fail it nope got it
okay three two one kaboom oh oh well
that ain't good
I found another way to kill everybody
good for me yay I did it though I got
underworld splitting alright so we got
to get back to the lever for this one
three two two three one pull the lever
to the right okay gotta use the UV light
on the panel okay this is where are the
numbers and I was like I wasn't sure
what these are to number of locations -
now restart the game in the 10 numerical
pad enter to zero zero zero 1 because
all right so now I need to enter two
zero zero one
oh boy
whoa okay I know what this is okay this
is making sense now because remember
that thing that pointed at Pluto and I
even called out was that Pluto it wants
you to say
[Music]
oh hello what are you what do you go to
I don't know what you do what does it do
ah press the red button for to get it
lock key lock to open up o to open up
the right side panel okay
oh and press that red button four times
Oh what the hell do it what am i doing
huh
I got no idea well that's a bad thing
it's gonna come right back down on it
isn't it
hello what the [ __ ] is that where's her
baby in space why is there space baby
set a reference to 2001 Space Odyssey my
be ok alrighty then
oh I think I think I know what the
problem was the game didn't recognize or
didn't want to give me the benefit of
the doubt of knowing but I do know
that's a D for now because that's out
there so I think I needed that before ok
so now hopefully hopefully it'll let me
do it so d1 4 and 7 B this there we go
now it's gonna let me do it ok so now I
enter the other code which for clarity's
sake the number comes from this right
here 4 0 to 0 how would anyone have
known that my goodness 4 0 to 0 and that
cracks that and then you wait and so
somehow in the 15th ending you get this
code which is yellow red blue blue
yellow red blue blue and that opens that
how the Fricka frac would you have known
any of that all right here we go oh oh
ok
the city struck back alright that's all
of them except the last one which is
actually I believe not actually one
but it's actually a thing I'm not on a
percent sure I'm pretty sure but I'm
boink okay no not this hey man man I
need to take a bathroom break stay here
for a moment wait what is this panel for
I don't bother this is a coffee machine
why is it so strange I don't know it
just appeared here one day sometimes it
shows ads on the screen you can order
some coffee while I'm gone there's a red
button okay but don't take too long what
love that I didn't even know was by the
same developers with the maker of papers
please but goddamn so that I can't gush
enough about how cool this was as an
experience I mean it would have taken me
so unbelievably long to actually
meticulously go through everything and
try to explore all the actual endings
there were some leaps of logic and I was
doing some pretty good jobs making these
leaps of logic but man as I got farther
along it was just impossible to go
through so I'm sorry I had to consult a
guide but this was worth seeing all the
endings so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see other
cool games like this I will put a link
in the description to my awesome games
playlist there's hundreds of cool games
like this not exactly like this not
anywhere near cool is this but some that
are cool or cooler maybe you'll have to
find out for yourself but thank you
everybody again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
okay Candyman coming for me